let's look at an application of Newton's
second law for a system of objects so
what I want to consider is a system of
pulleys and n masses so I'll have a
fixed surface here a ceiling and from
the ceiling we'll hang a pulley which
I'm going to call pulley a and this
pulley will have a rope attached to it
or wrapped around it and here we have
object one and the Rope goes around the
pulley and now it's going to go around
another pulley B and fixed to the
ceiling so that's fixed and hanging from
pole B is another mass - and our goal in
applying Newton's second law is to find
the accelerations of objects 1 and 2 now
how do we approach this well the first
thing we have to do is decide if we're
going to apply Newton's second law
what is the system that will apply it to
and there's many different ways to
choose the system when we look at this
problem we'll have several different
systems so let's consider the ones that
we're going to look at and the first one
is very simple it will be block 1 and
the second system that we look at will
call that a B is pulley a now that
brings us to an interesting question
about B pulley B and block 2 because we
could separately look at pulley B and we
could separately consider block 2 or we
consider them together and I want to
first consider separately pulley B and
block 2 now in some ways when you're
looking at a system of compound a
compound system and it has four object
it makes sense to apply Newton's second
law to each object separately but we'll
pay careful attention to the fact that
object 2 is connected to pulley B and
eventually we'll see that we can combine
these two things
so the next step is once we've
identified our object is to draw a
Freebody force diagrams for each of the
objects so in order to do that let's
start with object 1 and we want to
consider the forces on object 1 now that
brings us to our first issue about what
types of assumptions we're making in our
system for instance we have a rope
that's wrapped around this pulley and we
have two pulleys that in principle could
be rotating but what we'd like to do to
simplify our analysis so let's keep
track of some assumptions here our first
assumption will be that the mass MP of
pulley a and the mass of pulley B are
approximately zero now the reason for
that is that we're not going to consider
any of the fact that these objects have
to be put into rotational motion later
on the course will see that this will
give us a more complicated analysis
we're also going to assume that our rope
is not slipping so the rope is actually
is just slipping on the pulleys so what
that means is it's just the rope is
sliding as the objects move now again
what this is going to imply is that the
tension in the rope this rope is also is
slipping and the rope is massless as
well it's very light rope and all of
these assumptions we've seen when we
analyze ropes tell us that the tension T
is uniform in the rope so that's our
first assumption and we need to think
about this before we even begin to think
about the forces on the object and now
we can draw our forces what do we have
we have the gravitational force on
object 1 and now we can identify the
tension pulling in the string pulling
object 1 up now for every time we
introduce a Freebody diagram recall that
we have to choose what we mean by
positive directions and in this case on
pick a unit vector down J hat one down
so that's my positive direction for
force now before I write down all of
Newton's laws I'll just write down our
various force diagrams so for pulley a I
have two strings that are pulling it
downwards so I have tension and tension
and this string I'm going to call that
t2 is pulling is holding that pulley up
so we have the force diagram now I could
write em AG but we've assumed that the
pulley is massless and again I'll call J
hat a down for object to let's do pulley
B first now what are the forces on
pulley B I have strings on both sides T
pulley B is masses so I'm not putting
gravitational force and I'm pulling this
string is pulling be downwards so that's
t3 and again we'll write J hat be
downwards and finally I have block 2 so
I'll draw that over here I'll write
block 2 in fact let's save little space
here will have J hat be downwards now
block 2 what do we have there we have
the string pulling up block to which
we've identified as T 3 and we have the
gravitational force unblocked to
downward m2g and there we have J hat -
so I've now drawn the Freebody diagrams
and the various objects and that enables
me to apply Newton's second law for each
of these objects so let's begin we'll
start with object one we have remember
in all cases we're going to apply F
equals MA so for object one we have m1 G
positive downward minus T
is equal to m1a one and that's our F
equals MA on object one so sometimes
we'll divide distinguish that the forces
were getting from our free body diagrams
and a is a mathematical description of
the motion for block - we have m2 G
minus t3 is equal to m2 a - and now for
pulley a we have two T pointing
downwards - t - going upwards and
because pulley a is massless this is
zero even though pulley a may be this is
it's actually fixed - so it's not even
accelerating and what we see here is
this equation I'm going to quickly note
that it tells us that the string holding
pulley - up T 2 is equal to 2t now so we
can think of if we want them to know
what T 2 is we need to calculate T and
finally we have B and what are the
forces on B we have T 3 minus 2 T and
again pulley B is 0 and so we see that T
3 is equal to 2t now now if you think
about what I said before about combining
systems if we combine pulley B and block
to visually what we're doing is we're
just adding these two free body diagrams
together when we have a system B and
block
- let's call this J hat downwards and
when we add these Freebody diagrams
together you see that the t3 is now
internal force to the system it cancels
in pair by Newton's second law and all
we have is the two strings going up
so we have T and T and we have the
gravitational force
onward and separately when we saw that
t3 equals 2t and we apply it there then
if we consider a system B 2 and look at
our free body diagram we have m2 G minus
2t and notice we have the same result
there 2 T equals m2 a2 so in principle
now and I'll outline our equations we
have equation 1 we have equation 2 and
in these two equations we have 3
unknowns T a1 and a2 but only two
equations and so you might think what
about this missing third equation here
however in this equation we have a
fourth unknown t3 and this equation is
just relating to T and T 3 so in
principle we would have four unknowns
and three equations or if we restrict
our attention to these two equations we
have two unknowns three unknowns and two
equations are unknowns are T a1 and a2
these are our unknowns and now our next
step is to try to figure out what is the
missing condition that's relating these
some of these unknowns and that will be
a constraint condition that will analyze
next